bonsoir vous le savez cartes sur table
une fois par mois une heure de vérité
avec les acteurs connus ou anonymes de
la vie publique française
après le premier ministre monsieur
raymond barre ce soir monsieur georges
marchais et dans les mêmes conditions
il est bien sûr difficile d'imaginer
aujourd'hui une intervention plus
opportune elle est d'ailleurs attendu et
vous le savez monsieur marché pas
seulement par vos militants et par vos
alliés nous le verrons tout au long de
cette conversation mais tout de suite
une première question avec alain duhamel
inspirés par l'actualité que vient du
traité le journal d'antenne 2 oui alors
il nous le conseil des ministres de ce
matin
un texte qui a été adopté par le
gouvernement qui sera présenté au
parlement le mois prochain qui est un
texte politique important puisqu'il
s'agit de l' élection du parlement
européen au suffrage universel direct
alors dans ce texte il ya deux
dispositions politiques spécialement
importantes l'une qui prévoit que
l'élection se fera au mode de scrutin
proportionnel nationale et l'autre qui
prévoit explicitement que l'assemblée ne
pourra pas que l'assemblée européenne
future assemblée européenne ne pourra
pas dépasser ses compétences alors ma
question est très simple
monsieur marché est ce que ce texte vous
allez le voter vous et vos amis
évidemment il ne m'appartient pas et de
prendre d'ici la décision nous la
prendrons aux groupes parlementaires
communistes avec le parti je ne connais
pas en détail le texte dont vous parlez
il faut l'étudier mais en tout cas et je
n'ai aucune raison de mettre en doute ce
que vous venez de dire
s'il est rédigée de cette façon là cela
signifie qu'il y a
incontestablement de la part du
gouvernement à recul je rappelle en
effet simplement que en 1974 lors d'une
rencontre au sommet des différents
partenaires de la communauté un texte
avait été adopté qui sans aucun doute
allé dans le sens d' élargir les droits
et prérogatives de l'assemblée
européenne du parlement européen alors
par conséquent cela veut dire que il y a
recul par rapport à ce que fut à
l'époque la position de monsieur giscard
d'estaing recul également par rapport à
la position prise par différents hommes
politiques en france que je n'aurai pas
la cruauté une cité on n'a pas affecté
de citer le nom recul par rapport à
différents hommes d'état
des pays appartenant à la communauté je
pense en particulier à monsieur helmut
schmidt qui lui ne voulait faire rien
d'autre qu'une assemblée constituante du
parlement européen par conséquent cela
veut dire que la bataille que nous avons
mené les communistes mais pas nous seuls
aussi avec d'autres forces à porter ses
fruits ou dix on commence à porter ses
fruits
surtout si comme vous le dites
alors on a choisi comme mode de scrutin
la proportionnelle au plan national avec
une liste nationale oui absolument
au plus fort reste avec les 80 députés
français et bien cela veut dire à la
hulpe et vous voyez da du pc7 bonne
augure pour les organisations syndicales
qui vont organiser la grande grève du 24
mai c'est à veut dire qu'on peut faire
reculer ce pouvoir puisque sur cette
question aussi importante
il recule quelle sera notre position ça
il faut la priori nous en délibérerons a
priori pas avoir d'à priori finalement
favorable à ces pas personnellement je
n'ai pas de position personnelle lorsque
la question m'a été posée récemment dans
une émission vous étiez d'ailleurs alain
duhamel
j'ai rappelé la position élaboré par
deux parties en juillet 1976 j'étais en
vacances en corse d'ailleurs le bureau
politique avait adopté un communiqué
dans laquelle il disait à peu près ceci
ce n'est pas le mode de scrutin pour
nous qui est en cause pas tout le
problème est de savoir si on donnera où
on ne donnera pas des droits nouveaux au
parlement européen et d'autres parties
avait rappelé son opposition absolue à
toute atteinte à toute restriction de
l'indépendance de la souveraineté en mai
la france vraiment c'est le cas alors
par conséquent si dans le texte présenté
par le gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale
il y a des garanties sur ce plan alors
je reprend la formule que j'avais
examiné au cours de la veille utiliser
pardon au cours de cette émission nous
examinerons monsieur georges marchais
vous avez répété hier devant le sommet
de la gauche
d'après ce que nous savons en tout cas
nous allons aller au pouvoir et nous
voulons aller au pouvoir et pour quoi
faire pour gérer cette société si comme
le fait monsieur bart ou probablement
mieux que lui selon vous ou alors pour
instaurer déjà la transition vers le
socialisme
votre question d'abord d'un parce
qu'elle va me permettre
je lis la presse ce que disent les
journalistes
alors il semble qu'on s'interroge est ce
que les communistes veulent aller au
gouvernement alors très clairement je
dis oui nous voulons il nous voulions
absolument est allé et lorsque nous
avons commencé la bataille pour élaborer
le programme commun de la gauche en 1959
oui nous l'avons fait avec cette
perspective là parce que l'expérience
montre depuis 30 ans qu'en gouvernement
ou ne sont pas présents les
représentants des travailleurs mène
toujours une politique contraire aux
intérêts des travailleurs du peuple et
de la nation elle-même par conséquent
nous ne voulons pas aller au
gouvernement parce que notre parti
serait atteint d'une espèce de maladie
on voudrait ministre à tout prix 9
nous voulons aller au gouvernement pour
mettre en oeuvre ces deuxième aspect
alors de ma réponse une autre politique
ah non non non non pas pour faire la
politique de monsieur bah le slogan de
monsieur bart qu'est ce que c'est
austérité sous emploi chômage misère
pour la sauce de ben vu par vous vues
par mois et par des millions et des
millions de françaises et de français
et vu aujourd'hui et c'est important par
la cgt la cfdt force ouvrière la cftc la
cgc savez du monde n'ont donc pas seul à
dire que c'est une mauvaise politique
alors nous nous voulons mettre en oeuvre
une autre politique la politique du
programme comme alors vous me demandez
c'est troisième aspect de votre question
est ce qu'il s'agit d'un programme
sociaux
liste de transition de transitionnelle
il ne s'agit pas d'un programme
socialiste le socialisme c'est encore
autre chose d'ailleurs récemment un
homme politique disait que il attendait
que le parti communiste défini sa
position sur la société socialiste
je réponds à cet homme politique que
sans aucun doute il n'a pas lu les
travaux de notre 22e congrès parce
qu'ils sont précises sur cette question
est jusqu'à présent dans ce pays
aucun parti se réclamant du socialisme
n'a été aussi loin que nous sommes allés
nous pour dire voilà la conception que
nous avons non seulement de la marche à
la société socialiste non seulement de
la voie pour aller aux socialistes mais
de la société socialiste elle même alors
le programme commun n'est pas programme
socialiste
est ce que c'est une transition
le mot ne me semble pas bon confort
parce que transition veut dire
automatismes or il n'y a pas
d'automatisme ce qui est vrai c'est que
selon nous communisme et ça c'est notre
point de vue la mise en oeuvre du
programme commun j'abrège en renforçant
considérablement des positions de la
classe ouvrière en affaiblissant des
positions des grands monopoles en
montrant ce que la gauche unie peut
faire notre opinion est que cela créera
des conditions favorables pour que le
peuple français décident librement un
jour d'aller vers la société socialiste
en ce sens le programme commun frais la
voix ouvre la voie
créer les conditions peut créer des
conditions favorables vers la société
socialiste
mais là encore n'ayez aucun doute
monsieur le socialisme c'est non
seulement notre objectif c'est notre
raison d'être est alors est ce que par
exemple on peut imaginer si justement la
première législature si vous l'emportez
créé les conditions comme vous dites que
par exemple avec la seconde législature
ce soit le socialisme ce n'est pas non
ce n'est pas obligatoire non mais ce que
cette imaginables
est ce que c'est possible ça c'est les
français qui en décideront par la voie
du suffrage universel
mais voyez maintenant nous gagnons mais
pourrait faciliter leur choix puisque
vous allez établir les conditions qu'ils
conduiront tout doucement vers le
socialisme
nous allons pouvoir la gauche unie qui
peuvent nous mettons en oeuvre notre
programme commun un bon programme commun
bien actualisé correspondant bien à la
situation et aux aspirations des
travailleurs et des masses populaires
dans ces conditions je ne doute pas que
par la voie du suffrage universel dans
cinq ans les travailleurs confirmeront à
ce moment là je pense que la gauche unie
présentera un nouveau programme qui sans
doute ira un peu plus loin dans la voie
des réformes de structure voilà comment
nous voyons cette question décideront on
parle justement vous pariez des
problèmes de l'actualisation des
programmes communs les négociations
commencées hier
alors certains de vos alliés ont eu
l'air de penser que la publication d'un
certain nombre de chiffres par le parti
communiste quelques jours avant cette
réunion sur l'actualisation risquait
d'effrayer une fraction de l'électorat
modéré l'électorat qui hésitait ce que
ça vous paraît possible
d'abord nos partenaires n'ont pas pu
dire ça voilà si le dise surtout pas la
veille de la négociation pas puis
personnes et comprendraient plus rien
puisque dans la lettre que françois
mitterrand m'avait envoyé pour confirmer
en réponse à celle que moi même je lui
avais adressé pour organiser la réunion
ii sommer dans cette lettre il disait
l'ensemble de ces mesures parce que lui
il proposait aussi une série de mesures
c'est le parti socialiste qui a commencé
par rendre publiques ses propositions
pour actualiser le programme commun
cette lettre se termine par la phrase
suivante
l'ensemble de ces mesures sera chiffré
est intégré
les équilibres financiers globaux du
programme commun par conséquent françois
mitterrand envisagé lui aussi le chiffre
attendu attendait et alors on a clarifié
cette question et notre prise de
position n'a pas pu gêner le parti
socialiste puisque un homme comme gaston
defferre qui est unitaire mais pas trop
quand même puisque il n'a pas appliqué à
marseille les décisions concernant les
élections municipales
j'ai noté que dans le provençal il avait
déclaré ceci comme on lui demandait si
la publication des chiffres
quarante huit heures avant le débat qui
mitraille avec fois avec bar ne gênerait
pas de premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
monsieur de faire a estimé qu'au
contraire il pourrait lui servir
c'est aussi mon opinion il aurait pu lui
serré mais bon vous l'avez c'est
vraiment mieux marcher en toute
innocence
ah non non non pas en toute innocence
j'ai là votre question devient très
intéressant pourquoi nous l'avons fait
nous l'avons fait parce que le programme
commun c'est un bon programme
un programme qui dans ses structures
dans ses objectifs répond tout à fait
aux exigences de la situation actuelle
dans notre pays à condition qu'ils
soient que je rappelle que nous avions
élaboré
en fonction même de la crise de la
société existait déjà à cette époque
santé 11 elle était plus nette en 60 13
oui en 73 pour ceux qui ne voient pas
clair mais les communistes qui voit
clair l'avait vu eux dès 1971 où j'avais
publié au nom du parti en arctique dans
l'humanité qui s'intitulait vous voyez
de la société française en crimée et de
magie de méchantes langues vous dirait
monsieur marché qu'on peut facilement
trouver même des des textes de
l'humanité ou du parti communiste qui
remonte à beaucoup plus tôt et qu'il
estime que la société française dans
frida société française pour vous vous
le voyez toujours là alors là il y avait
une analyse précise des conditions et
des raisons profondes des causes
profondes de la crise que nous
connaissons maintenant alors et c'est à
partir de là que nous avons élaboré
notre programme changer de cap qui pour
une large part a servi de base à
l'élaboration du programme commun de la
gauche donc le programme commun est bon
cependant depuis 1971 soit depuis 1972
les choses ont bougé on ne reste jamais
sur place la crise et approfondie les
difficultés sont infiniment plus grande
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne l'étaient qu'elle
ne l'était à l'époque encore pour les
travailleurs et les masses populaires
l'inflation continue il ya chômage le
chômage a triplé
il y avait cinq cent mille chômeurs à
l'époque la meilleure forme il
maintenant et je pourrai comme ça
développer une série de choses dans ces
conditions alors nous estimons donc
qu'il convient d' actualiser le
programme commun de le mettre à jour
car justement il ya une question que les
radicaux de gauche ont posées à propos
de l'actualisation du programme commun
et c'est sur la fameuse phrase vous
savez on a parlé très souvent mais elle
est très importante
à la demande de la majorité des
travailleurs d'une entreprise qui
souhaitent que leur entreprise soit
nationalisée en plus de la liste des
entreprises qui sont sur la liste déjà
des nationalisations
ça pourrait être examiné et
éventuellement votée par le parlement si
la gauche l'emporté alors les radicaux
de gauche ont l'air de considérer qu'au
fond c'est un peu la voie ouverte
d'autres nationalisations éventuel
d'ailleurs dire on peut tout à fait
imaginer que c'est une usine est en
difficulté les travailleurs est en
vigueur nationalisé par exemple alors
est ce que votre avis vous pouvez vous
georges marchais avoue georges marchais
secrétaire général du parti communiste
envisagé de renoncer à cette phrase à
vous prenez les choses par le petit bout
de la lorgnette comme dirait jacques
martin les nations ce problème là est un
problème tout à fait secondaire par
rapport à l'ampleur de la tâche que nous
avons à accomplir d'abord viendront vous
posant deux questions
prenant le petit bout de la lorgnette
déjà qui touche pas mal de monde mais
vous comment ça touche pas mal de monde
ça touche personne non mais ça intéresse
beaucoup de gens nous disons simplement
ceci aux travailleurs
vous avez le droit de demander les
nationalisations de votre entreprise
je vous faut c'est avec ce droit
d'ailleurs ils ont déjà maintenant en
principe à travail à des travailleurs
peuvent se réunir en assemblée générale
ils peuvent voter une résolution exiger
de leurs députés qu'il ils sont déjà ce
droit ils peuvent bien et ensuite de
toute façon il ne peut pas y avoir de
nationalisation en dehors d'une décision
prise par l'assemblée nationale et par
conséquent
les patrons des entreprises n'ont aucune
raison de crâne avec cette petite phrase
skis à la seule chose c'est que ce droit
qui existe en réalité pour les
travailleurs est de demander une
nationalisation est bien là maintenant
il est dans un programme commun de
gouvernement nous trouvons que c'est une
bonne chose donc elle doit rester dans
le programme commun peut-être vous la
changerait de place où elle restera là
on a désigné une commission qui va
travailler mais je ne vois pas pour
quelle raison on priverait les
travailleurs du droit s'il le juge utile
regardez par exemple des sidérurgistes
là en ce moment à des clans la
sidérurgie et menaçait de 20 minutes
licenciement alors que nous nous ne
cessons de verser de l'argent moi je ne
cesse comme vous d'ailleurs comme tous
les français
nous ne cessons de payer des impôts et
le gouvernement il ne cesse pas de
verser de l'argent au bar honda
sidérurgie et malgré ça on va licencier
20 mille travailleurs et bien les
sidérurgistes
ils viennent de se prononcer ils ont
même voté ils ont fait je crois un
référendum ils disent il faut
nationaliser la sidérurgie
c'est bon ça c'est démocratique mais les
radicaux de gauche je pensais pas la
sidérurgie pensez probablement à autre
chose pensez par exemple à des petits
que des moyens entre besoin d'être en
difficulté entreprise qu'est ce que vous
voulez on n'envisage pas de nationaliser
du coup andré normes et concret non mais
concrètement pour parler de choses vous
disiez vous même de choses sérieuses il
se peut il ya toujours des entreprises
qui sont en difficulté
elle a toujours bon il se peut très bien
que les salariés d'une entreprise en
difficulté si une disposition comme ça
dans le programme commun se disent les
choses ne vont pas très bien de notre
entreprise nous on demande à
nationalisation
vous savez les parties en tout cas le
parti communiste et d'un parti
responsable et ce qui nous intéresse ce
n'est pas de nationaliser une petite
entreprise comportant quelques dizaines
ou quelques centaines de travailleurs ce
qui nous intéresse
et c'est le sens de nos compositions
déjà de nos décisions qui sont contenus
dans le programme commun et des
propositions que nous faisons ce qui
nous intéresse c'est de nationaliser les
entreprises qui jouent un rôle essentiel
dans l'économie française et qui pour le
moment sont sous la coupe des grands
monopoles privés voilà ce qui nous
intéresse avant d'en reparler jaune est
sur les chiffres monsieur fabre les a
trouvés et je crois qu'il a dit hier
prématuré hasardeux est-ce que vous
souhaitez que le parti socialiste publie
lui aussi ces chiffres et que la
discussion soit beaucoup plus clair film
question d'arriver
pourquoi je suppose vous avez des doutes
à la ou françois mitterrand dit il va
falloir chiffre est trop grand commun en
commun non il sait pas danser lentz pas
danser il dit faux chiffres faux
chiffres et c'est normal nous allons
discuter wire de l'actualisation du
programme commun ça concerne la vie des
français l'avenir des français et vous
voudriez qu'on règle une question aussi
capital aussi fondamentale d'or entre
quelques-uns dans le secret des états
majors politiques
alors qu'il y va vous avez commencé par
là vous avez dit vous même c'est d'un
projet de société qu'il s'agit par
conséquent les français doivent être
informés des positions de nos
différentes formations
les français doivent même est informé de
la discussion
moi par exemple quelqu'un m'avait posé
la question je me souviens mais c'est
vrai qu'à l'âge vous m'aviez demandé
qu'elles veulent mais moi est ce que
vous seriez d'accord pour que antenne 2
donne en direct la discussion avec des
socialistes et des radicaux de gauche
je vous ai dit moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord j'aurais souhaité que ces
discussions que nous avons eues hier au
siège des radicaux de gauche soit donné
en direct comme ça l'éléphant alors que
la proposition voulons pas fait alors
faire la proposition et vous savez
pourquoi bon monsieur françois
mitterrand n'a pas paru disposé hier à
accepter de nouvelles nationalisations
comme vous le souhaitez s'ils ne
changent pas d'avis comment vous faites
françois mitterrand voulait me dire à
l'instant que le bureau du parti
socialiste ce soir dans un communiqué
déclare qu'il ne veut ni restera ni
élargir le programme commun alors faut
discuter sur le fond qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça ça veut dire tout et rien
quant au fond ni restreint denis élargir
mais passé le smic 200 à 220 mille
anciens francs c'est bien élargie non
s'élargit cette actualisation ses plans
c'est actuelle s'est actualisée le
programme commun sailor et leurs ébats
le bureau exécutant la question que nous
c'est la question que nous lui avons
posé hier si le programme est bombay a
besoin d'être mises à jour
d'ailleurs j'ai dit à françois
mitterrand vous m'avez vous même envoyé
une lettre de six pages avec des
propositions bien
ak nous avons mis ça nous évidemment
rendez vous
l'été nous avons nous pu blié non
propositions et nous les avons chiffré
et nous avons chiffré
alors pourquoi parce que y'a quand même
toute une série de mesures qui sont
nécessaires
est-ce que l'on peut ne pas tenir compte
qu'il ya 9 millions et nuit de
travailleurs qui gagnent moins 250 mille
anciens francs par mois comment on peut
vivre avec moins de 150 mille anciens
francs par mois
est-ce que l'on peut ne pas tenir compte
qu'il y à un million et demi de chômeurs
est ce que l'on peut ne pas tenir compte
qu'il est que les allocations familiales
ont perdu 30 9,6 pour cent de leur
pouvoir d'achat
en 20 ans dans sur le plan économique et
social es jeune et que prend que
quelques exemples et ça pose un problème
un million et demi de chômeurs il est
évident qu'il faut actualiser le
programme commun dans ce domaine
deuxièmement on est tranquille
deuxièmement il ya le problème des
libertés de la démocratie les radicaux
en parle des socialistes en parle
nous nous avons adopté une charte des
libertés qui s'appelle vivre libres nous
nous avons versé au dossier de la audi
nous nous sommes prêts à l'intégrer dans
le programme commun troisième mais il y
a le problème de la politique extérieure
sur laquelle nous reviendrons sans doute
il anticipe par ailleurs un certain
nombre de biens attendait alors nous
avons donc dit à nos partenaires sur ces
questions là il faut se mettre à jour et
alors depuis 1972 des événements très
importants sont intervenus dans le
domaine de la sidérurgie du pétrole et
de l'automobile
je ne développe pas tout le monde les
connaît et en même temps donc se poser
le problème de la sidérurgie du pétrole
et de l'automobile il se trouve
je n'ai manqué tout à l'heure qu'on a
dilapidé notre argent en le distribuant
aux grands monopoles patrons de ces
entreprises
dans ces conditions nous faisons une
proposition elle est sain le programme
commun près vous
ayez la prise de participation
majoritaire dans le pétrole et dans la
sidérurgie
nous proposons de transformer cette
prise de participation majoritaire en
nationalisation franches
un point c'est tout si on vous répond
deuxième attendait deuxième 1 nous avons
versé je crois 200 milliards oui à
peugeot citroën non seulement nous
disant oui c'est inadmissible on ne peut
pas admettre que des fonds publics qui
manquent quand pour le logement les
écoles et autres choses soient
distribués à ces gens là gratuitement
nous avons donc dit alors nationale i
nous proposons donc qu'une seule
nationalisation de plus c'est tout bon
mais leur admettons vouliez vous même ce
sont vos propositions voilà le policier
est raisonnable admettons parce que
donne à vos partenaires de vous le dire
mais admettons annoncé par des
partenaires puisque les journalistes
vous parlez vous écrivez si je vous dis
j'en crois ce que vous écrivez ce que
vous dites
nous aurions fait des propositions
démentiel alors à moins qu on dise qu'il
est démentiel dans ce pays de donner
deux cent vingt mille francs de salaire
minimum se donner tout pas sur ce point
là tant d'ingrédients 100 mille francs 2
minimum redresse au mieux alors que
c'est démentiel
il faut le dire franchement autrement il
faut voir que les propositions que nous
faisons sont en tout point conforme au
programme commun de gouvernement
cyriaque l'hymne national alors j'écris
une nationalisation de fusion revient
aux nationalisations
bon vous vous proposez vous venez très
bien de l'expliquer vous proposer les
nationalisations pour ces trois cas le
pétrole la sidérurgie l'automobile à la
sépaq en exclusion nous prendre aux gens
de transformer la petite compacte on y
passe sur majorité est ce que j'ai dit
pétrole et la sidérurgie en
nationalisation franche bon et nous
proposons une seule et unique
nationalisation de plus celle de peugeot
citroën admettons que vos partenaires
eux estiment qu'ils préféreront rester à
la formule qui était prévu à l'origine
c'est à dire prise de participation
majoritaire
les spis pa bon qu'est-ce que vous
faites ils disent non on avait dit prise
de position
re prise de participation majoritaire on
reste la prise de participation
majoritaire s'adjugera ça dure deux mois
de négoce hors frais c'est pas ça ce
serait ce serait à mon avis prendre une
lourde responsabilité parce que j'ai
quand il expliqué tout à l'heure que
l'aggravation de la crise les
difficultés plus grandes pour vivre que
connaissent des millions et des millions
de français le chômage chômage énorme
un million et demi de chômeurs 6 à 700
milles jeunes et bien c'est là une
situation économique et sociale qui
suppose que la gauche prenne les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer sa politique de
progrès social or si nous ne le faisons
pas si nous ne nous donnons pas les
moyens nous ne pourrons pas réaliser des
objectifs sociaux sur laquelle nous nous
sommes engagés
or ces capitales ça vous avait demandé
le 14 juillet à lyon gouvernement pour
gérer la crise ah non nous voulons aller
au gouvernement
oui pas pour gérer la crise pour faire
une politique au service des
travailleurs par conséquent refusé de se
donner les moyens nécessaires pour une
grande politique pour développer la
production donc et pour faire une grande
politique sociale c'est une lourde
responsabilité
donc vos alliés doivent ou devrait
accepter a même un reste on préfère
autrement dit vous dites doivent aide
devrait selon moi on être conséquent
avec soi-même dire nous voulons mettre
un terme ou plutôt nous rend dans la
première phase parce qu'on mettra pas
encore définitivement un terme mais nous
voulons nous donner les moyens du plein
emploi du progrès social de la
satisfaction des besoins collectifs des
travailleurs et des masses populaires
dire cela suppose s'en donner les moyens
c'est à dire qu'il faut les
nationalisations de la même façon on a
crié quand on a vu nos chiffres les
impôts et oui il faut bien il faut bien
prendre l'argent quelque part
pour le moment on prend l'argent
dans les poches des gens qui n'en n'ont
pas nous nous disons il faut prendre
l'argent dans la poche dans les coffres
porte plutôt des riches
bon allez dire justement une question
précise à partir de ce point précis vous
venez d'évoquer tout à fait à tort ou à
raison on a compris en tout cas on l'a
dit on l'a écrit beaucoup de gens dire
et écrire on a compris que vous vouliez
relever le smic en gros disons d'un gros
tiers que vous vouliez de continuer à
augmenter mais alors naturellement un
niveau bien moindre
au moins jusque pratiquement huit mille
francs mais de façon dégressive
bon et puis que à partir de 8000 francs
au contraire il n'y avait pas à ce
moment là donnez d'augmentation
supplémentaire mais qu'en revanche il y
aurait forcément une augmentation des
impôts sur les revenus élevés donc ça
veut dire qu'en réalité il y aurait là
une sorte de limite et puis que tous les
gens au dessus de 8000 francs aurait des
salaires par hypothèse qui
n'augmenterait pas et puis des impôts
qui augmenterait sa fait une diminution
de valeur sa touche les cannes les
travailleurs indépendants les commandes
une vraie question est oui
nous avons délibérément fait le choix de
donner satisfaction en priorité à ceux
qui ont le plus de mal à vivre et nous
pensons qu'il ya une grande différence
entre la situation que connaissent les 9
millions de salariés qui gagnent moins
de 250 mille anciens francs par mois et
ce qu'ils gagnent 880000 anciens francs
membres nous avons fait ce choix
voilà pourquoi notre politique est la
suivante dans ce domaine d'abord
l'augmentation des salaires le smic vous
en avez parlé je ne reviens pas c'est
clair
l'augmentation des salaires en 1980 pour
les trois années 1977 dans 118 119 80
sera l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
attention pas les salaires du pouvoir
d'achat sera de 10%
on peut considérer par exemple qu'un
salarié qui gagne
trois cent cinquante mille francs bien
il aura une augmentation durant ces
trois années de son pouvoir d'achat
d'environ 10% contre attendant par an
10% est alors d'une manière dégressive
jusqu'à 880000 repenser à sa mamie voilà
voilà notre position 8830 dia alors cela
étant dit ce sera déjà une drôle de
modifications par rapport à la situation
actuelle
parce qu'alors si vous me permettez bien
que c'était pas sur antenne 2 v la
télévision c'est la télévision je tiens
à relever que monsieur bart a peut-être
n'at-il pas fait exprès mais enfin il a
trompé d'abuser les français en disant
que l'augmentation des salaires en 1976
avait été de 15%
ce n'est pas exact l'augmentation de 15%
a été donnée à des ouvriers travaillant
dans des entreprises employant plus de
10 travailleurs mais non compris le
secteur public
ce qui fait qu'en définitive la moyenne
d'augmentation des salaires en 1976 est
d'environ 11%
or comme la vis des prix de la cgt et de
12,6 pour cent
ça veut dire que de pouvoir d'achat des
travailleurs a baissé de 1,6 pour cent
si monsieur bart avait accepté la
confrontation que je lui ai proposé on
aura plus qu arrive geste en hausse 30
devant le français on n'a pas envie
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de questions
quand on ferme va hanter ce bar et
pouvoir d'achat alors donc vous voyez il
y aura l'augmentation des salaires
je souhaite rendre cela étant dit ces
gens là qui ont le salaire dont vous
parlez de 890 nancière francs qui sont
couverts par les conventions collectives
c'est vrai qu'ils n'auront pas
d'augmentation de leur pouvoir d'achat
y'aura maintien du pouvoir d'achat mais
augmentation des impôts tant de domaines
on sait qu'il y aura maintien du pouvoir
d'achat leur salaire en fonction de
l'échelle mobile
donc cela ils sont
à 880 milles anciens francs par mois ils
ont la garantie
nous ne progressons pas mais notre
pouvoir d'achat est maintenue et les
implants après des infos alors revenons
au lin et on règle ça d'un coup il y
aura effectivement une augmentation des
impôts
trois types d'impôts d'abord un impôt
sur le capital c'est à dire sur les
entreprises en gros 1 c'est normal
ensuite un impôt sur la fortune mais qui
nous visons avec l'impôt sur la fortune
ce sont les gens qui disposent de plus
de 200 millions d'anciens francs
ça touche du monde mais quelques
centaines de milliers sans doute pas
plus voyez par conséquent disons que
celui qui a son logement ou un bel
appartement même qui a une résidence
secondaire car une voiture non celui là
il ne sera pas touché par l'impôt sur la
fortune
déjà 200 millions c'est pas mal mais
nous pensons qu'il est normal que ceux
qui ont une telle fortune et un appeau
voilà le second d'impôts et le troisième
un pot alors c'est un drapeau de
caractère conjoncturel sur les
entreprises qui pratiqueront une
politique des prix inflationnistes par
conséquent contrairement à ce que vous
dites monsieur fallon hamel dans le
monde est contrôlé gens qui en huit cent
quatre-vingt mille anciens france il est
vrai qu'ils ne verront que maintenir
leur pouvoir d'achat
ils bénéficieront néanmoins d'une série
de choses
il y aura quand même le plein emploi et
vous savez les cadres ce qui au dessus
sont au chômage sont intéressés il y
aura la satisfaction des besoins
collectifs 50 aussi coureur et il y aura
une politique d' impôt qui sera orienté
dans le sens de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure quand on prend nos chiffres qui
ont dit à ces gens là vous serez écrasés
d'impôts
c'est une contre vérité notre ligne on
peut la résumer d'une phrase ou plutôt
de trois phrases
premièrement
je mens des impôts pour les travailleurs
et les masses populaires et c'est juste
parce qu'il en paie trop d'impôts sur le
revenu tva plus à pau locaux qu'ils
deviennent extraordinairement lourd donc
allègements pour cela ensuite il y aura
un impôt nous qui frappera le capital et
les grosses fortunes
ce n'est que justice on ne peut pas
parler de réduire les inégalités et de
mettre un terme aux injustices si on ne
ne pratique pas cette politique nous
pourrions encore utiliser un certain
nombre de chiffres mais naturellement
l'heure tourne
ce qui me frappe c'est que vous parlez
de tout cela et puis vous savez dans les
textes et pourquoi comme vous je
laissais la même façon vous dit tout ça
au futur comme si vous impose rien à la
réalité presque par décret c'est comme
si la réalité de l'être celle que vous
voulez ça qui me frappe moi non non non
non non parce qu'il ya l'environnement
international
il ya les mêmes des entreprises
elles-mêmes attendait l'environnement
international vous savez il faut quand
même pas exagérer un an ferme les
frontières
non non je sais bien qu'on a répété
depuis des années que les causes de la
crise d'ailleurs on a beaucoup varier
les positions variées au début on a
commencé à nous dire oui effectivement
il ya une espèce de maladies là on voit
pas bien ce que c'est mais mme effective
maria quelque chose
après on a dit abbas et le pétrole selon
nous la tire attention sur le fait que
le réajustement du prix du pétrole
en 1973 n'est intervenu que pour 3% dans
une hausse des prix qui a dépassé des
deux chiffres et en 1976 l'augmentation
du prix du pétrole n'est intervenu que
pour 0,5 pour cent dans une inflation
située aussi à deux chiffres
par conséquent c'est pas le pétrole
tadic dont un passant je vous recommande
une petite lecture
moi je lis pas l'anglais
peu de chiffres encore non gardé il ya
une revue américaine qui a vient de
publier la situation des 50 plus grandes
et plus riches entreprises américaines
vous connaissez ça c'est dans fortune je
vous le donne et après comme par hasard
histrion rentrer en france que dans la
première entreprise c'est exxon la
quatrième c'est exact la 5ème ses
mobiles
la sixième c'est standard oil california
la 7e cellule folle
autrement dit sur les dix premières
entreprises
je vois cinq sociétés pétrolières mettez
vous eh bien j'avais pas tromper les
français car j'avais dit à monsieur
fourcade que j'avais pas dire ce fameux
raquette de 4 milliards organisé par les
sociétés américaines vous en trouvez la
confirmation ne relancera donnera
conséquent ne parlerais pas ne parlons
pas de deux je ne dis pas que les
événements internationaux n'y a pas une
certaine situation et conjoncture qui
peut jouer
seulement voilà la réalité elle est la
suivante et je pense d'ailleurs que dans
le débat de l'autre soir il a été
faussée au départ justement parce que
l'analyse profonde des causes de la
crise n'a pas été bien fait vous avez
d'autres occasions de marquer
simplement les causes profondes de la
crise il ne faut pas aller les chercher
ailleurs
il faut aller les chercher dans une
politique délibérée mener par les grands
monopoles qui se résume en deux idées
essentielles
la première c'est la recherche du profit
maximum pas les grands monopoles la
suraccumulation du capital et la
deuxième ce sont les gâchis
extraordinaire et je ne résiste pas un
homme n'aurait pas privé l'esprit que
résister vous le montrez ce spectacle
extraordinaire
voilà envoyer la caméra vous voyez cette
photo qu'est ce qu'on a à dire après ça
attendait cette photo c'est une
entreprise qui appartient à rhône
poulenc péage
aussi on fabrique dans cette entreprise
du field ac thann
la production de cette entreprise est de
7000 tonnes par an et la consommation
française en fils d'acétone et
précisément elle aussi de 7000 tonnes
autrement dit voilà une entreprise
moderne
les téléspectateurs ont vu ultramoderne
qui assure les besoins de la france en
fils d'acétone et bien messieurs cette
entreprise elle est maintenant occupés
par les ouvriers qui la défendent
parce que rhône poulenc veut la fermer
et il veut la fermer pourquoi parceque
il s'implante au brésil en argentine et
en république fédérale
alors qu'est ce que vous ferez et en
république fédérale allemande alors
qu'elle est la conséquence cette usine a
coûté cher regarder ce beau matériel
il a d'autant plus coûter cher que c'est
du matériel d'importation c'est de la
machine outils ad pa france vient de
l'étranger et cela veut dire que si les
travailleurs de cette usine ne gagnez
pas il faudra s'approvisionner à
l'extérieur et payer en devises
voilà monsieur quand on parle des gâchis
qui a dans les chiffrages du programme
commun c'est un exemple et je peux vous
en prendre sens comme ça d'exemple les
gâchis sont là les causes donc de
l'inflation et du chômage sont dans ces
deux raisons fondamentales que je viens
d'évoquer de vendre alors il ya un autre
type de nationalisation sur lequel on
voudra votre avis et la nationalisation
de l'enseignement privé
vous savez que c'est un sujet qui est en
discussion en ce moment est-ce que
quelle est votre position là dessus est
ce que vous estimez comme le demandent
les parents d'élèves qu'atelier coup
comme le demande le secrétariat général
est ce que vous estimez qu'on peut
trouver un système pour qu'il soit plus
associé l'enseignement public sans être
nationalisées nous pour le moment nous
nous en tenons à
la position que nous avons définies avec
nos partenaires du programme commun
époux ce qui concerne la mise en
application
il est possible que dans la discussion
on envisage de faire preuve d'un peu
moins dix ans de de rigidité en tout cas
je ne pense personnel on fasse un autre
point hypothèse la gauche gagne l'année
prochaine pony c'était une hypothèse à
l'autre pour vous rappeler que l après
la libération quand les ministres
communistes pour la première fois était
entré au gouvernement le général de
gaulle avait dit qu' il fallait les
écarter de trois grands ministères qui
sont la défense l'intérieur et les
affaires étrangères est ce que le parti
communiste
si la gauche gagne accepterait toujours
d'être écarté de ses trois grands
ministères alors là vous êtes en plein
dans la discussion que nous avons eue
hier déjà mais parce que mais oui vous
n'avez pas bien lu il y a eu tout vous
dire moi toujours nous avons décidé donc
de discuter vous avez vu il ya une
commission composée de cinq
représentants par pas partir et alors il
y aura pour chacun de nos partis
l'homme qui nous représentait au comité
de liaison
c'est un peu compliqué pour ceux que ça
même si c'est compliqué donc il aura
pourtant il y aura cette personne là et
ensuite il y aura celui qui a conduit
les discussions pour ce qui concerne
l'économie et le social
celui qui a conduit à discussion pour ce
qui concerne les libertés
celui qui a conduit à discussion pour la
politique extérieure et ya un cinquième
personnage cinquième personnage qui aura
pour tâche d'accomplir la mission qui
est défini dans la résolution que nous
avons adoptée en commun c'est de définir
les conditions et modalités
d'application du programme primé à
formuler conditions et modalités
lyon parce qu'effectivement nous allons
vers des élections législatives
il ne s'agit pas là d'élection
présidentielle le rôle du président de
la république vous savez bien nous nous
considérons qu'il a outrepassé les
droits que lui donne la constitution
après l'élection au suffrage universel
de 1962 alors par conséquent lorsqu'il
ya eu des dernières élections
présidentielles françois mitterrand y
aller avec un programme équivalent rôle
d'un président de la république tout le
programme dans cette voie il s'agit d'un
programme de gouvernement
donc faut discuter de son adaptation
comme nous l'avons vu tout à l'heure
mais en même temps il faut aussi disputé
naturellement des conditions de travail
il s'agit pas de répartir les
portefeuilles s'agit pas de décider qui
sera ministre
il s'agit de définir quelles sont les
conditions maximum les conditions les
meilleures pour que contrairement à ce
qui s'est trop souvent hélas passé en
souvenez pas besoin de rappeler ces
choses que les français ne soient pas
déçus que la porte ses fruits
alors c'est à dire que les promesses
soient bien tenu alors il faut discuter
des conditions de travail du
gouvernement d'union de la gauche
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce que ça
veut dire j'aurais pas dans le détail
mais pour répondre à votre question je
dirai simplement ceci est bien les trois
parties doivent être partenaires à
égalité de droits et de devoirs
supplémentaires j'ai une notion
démocratiques élémentaires bien à la
fois dans l'élaboration et dans
l'application et croyez moi nous irons
nous aurons des ministres et assumeront
la responsabilité qu'on en doute six
saisons comme vous disiez autrefois
davantage peur oui voyez vous ça
correspond à peu près ce que je disais
égalité de droits et de voir s'il y
avait un gouvernement de 20 ou 21
ministres bien si cette ministre
communiste sera une chose raisonnable
alors maintenant vous me dites mais
alors lesquels
parce que la qualité des fonctions qui
semble pratiquement interdite aux exclus
tabou pour les connaissances pourquoi
vous avez vous interdire aux communistes
à moi pas moi que je sache on dit dans
ce pays que les hommes sont sur un pied
d'égalité
liberté égalité fraternité c'est une
devise ou une réalité ou un slogan
électoral donc elle devrait rapidement à
la constitution à la structure du
gouverneur clasico je ne vois pas
pourquoi
a priori on éliminerait les communistes
de responsabilité qu'ils peuvent qu ils
ont la qualité assuré jeudi compris les
trois dont je vous parlais la défense
nationale l'intérieur les affaires
étrangères et nous avons déjà eu sous le
général de brigade ministre de la
défense nationale m
riou françois pillou on va j'en avais
145 jours en dépendent et nous sommes en
mais cela étant communes de gauche cela
cela étant dit je tiens quand même à
attirer votre attention sur un fait
contrairement à
ce que vous semblez penser naturellement
nous ne pourrions pas accepter
discrimination une discrimination a
priori ou à notre égard ou nous à
l'égard de nos partenaires
ce ne serait pas une bonne chose ce ne
serait pas créer les meilleures
conditions pour réaliser avec succès le
programme commun cela étant dit je pense
que je ne ramène pas moi
la valeur des ministères ou des ministes
aux trois que vous venez d'énumérer
je considère que en dehors du ministère
de l'intérieur des affaires étrangères
et de la défense nationale
il est des ministères extrêmement
important juste vous avenir de notre
pays mais la justice d'éducation mais à
des problèmes tout ce qui touche n'a pas
seulement le ministère du travail
tout ce qui touche au développement
économique d'ailleurs vous avez vu nous
faisons des propositions c'est ce ce
monstrueux ministère des finances la
nous proposons nous de le couper en deux
nous pensons qu'il faudrait un ministère
du plan et bien être ministre du plan
vous croyez que c'est pas une grande
responsabilité dans un grand pays
grenoble par conséquent je crois qu'il
faut pas raisonner comme vous le faites
nommé pour prendre la question autrement
ça signifie que non seulement vous
demander votre place normale dans le
nombre des ministres globale mais aussi
que parmi les portefeuilles importants
je dis pas spécialement mais parmi les
portefeuilles importants
vous voulez aussi qu'est dans les
portefeuilles les plus importants un
tiers pour les communistes à tient pour
les socialistes un tir pour les autres
fois jeux de sport fait ses calculs vous
de la petitesse non on est communistes
on n'est pas comme ça je pense que il
faut vous prenez d'abord se mettre
d'accord sur un bon programme bien
actualisé correspondant bien la
situation nationale des français 1
ensuite il faut créer les conditions les
meilleures pour la réalisation c'est à
dire il faut un bon gouvernement
une équipe cohérente capable au premier
qui l'a dit une équipe cohérente et
capable elle doit reposer
sur les trois formations qui pour le
moment parce que c'est possible si dc e
la victoire d'ici les élections
législatives d'autres se rejoignent et à
nous nous devrions avenir compte
évidemment et qui dirige les dirige une
équipe qui repose pour l'essentiel sur
les trois formations dont je viens de
parler qui dirige l'équipe c'est le
président de la république qui désigne
le premier ministre en fonction de la
constitution mais moins 48 ou alors ce
sont les partis que la raison pour
laquelle comme je ne suis pas encore
président de la république je peux pas
vous dire qu'il sera premier ministre
vous travaillez monsieur marché une
boutade
vous travaillez avec françois mitterrand
depuis 12 ans vous espérez gouverner
l'an prochain avec lui est ce que vous
vous le considérez mais je me dérange
comme un allié totalement loyal
bah je pense que je réfléchis je
m'attendais pas à cette question
je pense que depuis que nous avons des
rapports
depuis que j'ai là se remplacer waldeck
rochet qui étend les malades dans les
conditions que vous savez si je fais le
bilan de nos rapports je pense qu'on
peut dire que nous avons coopéré dans de
bonnes conditions que nous avons été
loyal envers l'autre oui je crois qu'on
peut dire ça évidemment ça n'a pas été
sans difficultés peut-être lui même il a
t-il des reproches à me faire c'est
possible mais vous les fait pas il ne
fait pas mais si vous lui posiez la
question sans doute il vous tiendrai le
même raisonnement que moi cela n'a
jamais ça n'a pas été sans discussion
serrée parfois même mais je crois qu'on
peut dire mais c'est pas seulement à
l'actif de marché de mitterrand et de
femmes c'est avant tout à l'actif de nos
partis et des travailleurs et des masses
populaires qui soutiennent l'union de la
gauche
on peut donc dire que le bilan est
positif puisque l'union de la gauche a
été maintenue consolidé que s'ouvre
maintenant devant nous la perspective de
l'emporter je dis bien sourire la
perspective parce que ça va encore est
difficile nous ne gagnerons qu'à l'issue
d'un combat dur difficile
nos adversaires ne négligeront rien pour
essayer de se maintenir ils sont au
pouvoir depuis 20 ans ils ont tous les
pouvoirs
ils ont accaparé l'état s'est pas
seulement l'état udc l'état eu des airs
giscardien centriste et radicale serait
rien ils se sont tout accaparé
avons eu 10 ont tous les pouvoirs ils
vont tout faire pour essayer de le
garder
donc il va falloir lutter fermement et
encore renforcer la cohésion de l'union
de la gauche
alors si c'est comme ça seulement qu'on
peut voir les choses
je crois que le bilan est positif
il reste beaucoup de choses à résoudre
cela n'a pas été toujours sans
difficulté et nous en connaîtrons encore
mais où et nous avons été loyal l'un et
l'autre bien allier une autre question
sur le sujet tout à fait différent est
une question importante
le parti communiste français estiment
que dans les pays socialistes c'est le
débat d'idées qui devrait remplacer
toutes les formes de contraintes
politiques qui existent et là c'est la
position du parti communiste français il
l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
alors il ya une question je voulais vous
poser est ce que vous trouvez qu'il
serait qu'il est normal ou pas normal ce
que ça vous paraît demi cible que par
les moyens du débat politique bien
entendu je parle uniquement de sac par
les moyens du débat politique à
l'intérieur d'un pays socialiste on
puisse combattre pour revenir au
capitalisme de même que dans un pays
capitaliste on peut combattre par les
moyens politiques pour aller au
socialisme est ce que ça vous paraîtrait
normal par le débat d'idées toujours
mais vous n'avez pas lu notre 22e combat
merci là vous avez la réponse à votre
question dit là qu'est ce que nous
disons 22e congrès y compris dans la
société socialiste
nous reconnaissons le droit à
l'alternance mais tout à fait vous
parler de la france
par conséquent même si france non mais
bien sûr mais ce que je vous demandais
sais que vous le parti communiste
français a pris à plusieurs reprises
publiquement à propos des pays
socialistes ce qu'on appelle les pays de
l'est à plusieurs reprises il a dit
qu'il était lui parti communiste
français favorables à ce qu'il y ait des
débats d'idées et pas des mesures de
contrainte
1 c'est bien ce que vous avez absolument
alors je marche moi la question pour la
démocratie sociale dans la question que
je vous pose est ce que vous trouvez
légitime que par les mots normal que par
les moyens du débat politique des débats
d'idées dans des pays socialistes
existant aujourd'hui dans le pays de
l'est on puisse éventuellement demander
le retour au capitalisme sûr
envie ou ça il me semble que si dans les
pays socialistes
il existe une majorité de gens qui veut
revenir au système capitaliste il y
reviendrons je parle pas d'une majorité
éventuellement la minorité puisque les
minorités enfin vous le dites vous-même
les minorités peuvent vouloir s'exprimer
je veux dire mais alors écoutez il faut
formuler votre question autrement
d'alain duhamel
parce que c'est en clair votre affaire
alors est-ce que si une mineure
environnement je pose une autre question
si une minorité même une petite minorité
même quelques individus si vous voulez
qu'ils vivent dans un pays de l'est
aujourd'hui sont hostiles aux
socialistes y en a de bien avoir
bon si ces gens là ont envie eux de
faire campagne pour que l'on change de
régime et qu'on ait du socialisme au
capitalisme comme ailleurs on demande
d'aller du capitalisme au socialisme est
ce que vous trouvez normal que par les
moyens des débats d'idées je vous dis à
djougou est ce que vous trouvez ça
normal ou pas normal et j'ai eu raison
d'insister parce qu'à la troisième
reprise votre question est devenu père
oui
vous traînerez oui absolument notre
réponse
et à la question vous poser est la
suivante et nous l'avons dit
publiquement et clairement il faut dans
les pays socialistes ce n'est pas par la
contrainte par des mesures
administratives
alors parlons clairement part d
emprisonnement ou autres mesures procès
procès qu'il faut résoudre ces problèmes
quand se pose des problèmes de cette
nature avec des citoyens
il faut engager la bataille d'idées il
faut engager le débat d'idées voilà la
position et voilà la raison pour
laquelle à notre 22e congrès nous avons
clairement manifesté notre désaccord
avec le parti communiste de l'union
soviétique sur le problème qui touche
les problèmes qui touchent à la
démocratie socialiste il ya ce que selon
nous la démocratie socialiste suppose le
rejet absolu de toute forme de
contrainte et elle suppose au contraire
le débat d'idées et 3 1 pour ceux qui
voudraient revenir au capitalisme
si on a choisit pas on choisit parce que
pourquoi autre main pour ce qui concerne
est-ce que tel ou tel pays ce peu où se
trouve dans la situation de revenir à la
société capitaliste
alors là je ne peux pas répondre à cette
question parce que mais le droit des
individus éthique nigeria oignies
chinois je suis français c'est au peuple
appartenant à ces pays là qu'il
appartient de répondre à cette question
mais par contre la première la façon
dont vous l'avez posé là c'est d'autres
choses qu'il s'agit il s'agit de notre
idéal socialiste
or l'idéal socialiste ne supporte pas la
contradiction existant pour aller de
l'avant
le débat d'idées pour aller plus loin
ghellab aller plus loin sur ce même
terrain je crois vous n'avez jamais
répondu à cette question
l'union soviétique vous l'avez dit n'est
pas un modèle pour pour la france où le
socialiste est que vous l'imaginez
est ce que c'est encore un pays
socialiste on ne lui d'abord évidemment
ce n'est pas grave nous disons que ce
n'est pas un modèle
nous disons simplement que la société
socialiste que nous construirons dans
notre pays qui reposera sur un certain
nombre de principes sans lesquelles on
ne fait pas le socialisme c'est un bilan
sera une société socialiste aux couleurs
de la france nous avons nous nos
traditions nos particularités nos
habitudes nous avons l'acquis de siècle
de décennies de luttes de notre classe
ouvrière et de notes peuvent dans le
domaine des libertés de l'indépendance
de la souveraineté dans le domaine de la
culture et cetera et cetera
tout cela constitue un acquis vous
voudriez que c'est acquis on jette par
dessus bord mais cet acquis il
n'appartient pas à la bourgeoisie
la bourgeoisie il n'y a qu'une chose
qu'elle possède et que je lui laisse
c'est le droit d'exploiter les hommes de
réduire les sommes à la misère de faire
que dans notre pays à 16 millions de
pauvres
voilà ça c'est une liberté à l adresse
celle acquis de la lutte du peuple
français vous le savez bien et dense est
plus là
la soufrière et pour sa part depuis sa
fondation heureuse en 1920 le parti
communiste français a tenu sa place
par conséquent tout cela tout cet acquis
nous entendons le prendre en compte pour
construire une société socialiste qui
sera bien croyez-moi aux couleurs de la
france de notre drapeau tricolore il ya
une question qui sera peut-être la
dernière
mais alors cela étant dit alors oui
l'union soviétique est un pays
socialiste c'est évident d'ailleurs
personne mais pourquoi pourquoi nous
réussirions où les français réussir et à
créer cette société qui n'existe pas et
qui n'a pas pour vous deux modèles alors
que tant de gens ont échoué
est ce que les français sont plus malins
les avants très chagrin haye sur la lune
personnes y étaient allés alors les
dernières questions mais ce marché c'est
la conquête de la lune que l'on
promettait la lune mais voilà que vous
raisonnez comme comme une conne
qu'est ce que nous voulons non mais vous
l'avez expliqué il ya la nationale à
neuf pour notre peur nous voulons nous
voulons que nole que notre peuple que
nos travailleurs que notre peuple que
nos paysans bénéficient des richesses
qu'ils produisent
nous voulons deuxièmement qu'ils soient
maîtres de leur destin qu'ils ne soient
pas des robots qu'ils décident eux mêmes
de leur vie
et troisièmement nous nous voulons être
maîtres chez nous nous ne voulons pas
que la politique de la france soit faite
ailleurs qu'à paris nous brûlons
l'indépendance et la souveraineté tout
en développant la coopération
internationale à tous les niveaux voilà
ce que nous voulons nous voulons le
bonheur de notre peuple et vous appelez
ça la lune dans un pays riche comme le
nôtre qui possède des richesses
naturelles qui a une place ouvrière des
ingénieurs des techniciens des paysans
des savants d'une qualité extraordinaire
vous vous croyez que c'est leur
promettent la lutte nous avons les
moyens dans notre flash apparition avec
je laime je compte y je considère qu'il
est scandaleux d'entendre les hommes
politiques de la droite essayait
d'accréditer l'idée que la france serait
vouée au malheur que nos ouvriers nos
âges une op
dix ans serait vouée à connaître
l'abaissement le chômage et des
difficultés pour vivre dans un pays
comme le nôtre ce n'est pas vrai c'était
tout le thème de notre 22e congrès ni
regard on avait beaucoup j'aime pas
d'avoir réagi avec un peu de passion
mais c'est pas la lune c'est à portée de
notre peuple ce que nous proposons c'est
lui même qui décidera nous n'imposerons
pas en fait pas le bonheur d'un peuple
contre lui même c'est lui qui en
décidera mais c'est ça que nous propose
alors une dernière question monsieur
marché à votre 22e congrès justement le
parti communiste à renoncer à la
dictature du prolétariat mais il ne
s'était pas un recul mais il n'a pas
renoncé au rôle d'avant-garde ou rôle
dirigeant
alors si on se fonde sur les résultats
des dernières élections partielles ou
des dernières élections cantonales
et si comme on le dit beaucoup le parti
socialiste a plus de député et
éventuellement plus de ministres que
vous en 1978 comment est ce que le parti
communiste peut exercer concrètement ce
rôle d'avant garde
d'abord pourquoi vous me rapprocher de
vous reproche rien moi je vous pose une
question j'avoue nous rapprocher d'eux
d'aspirer à jouer un rôle d'avant-garde
se verrait bien jouer dans le meilleur
club pour moi aux possessionnais
non non je ne vous reproche rien dans
effectivement nous aspirons à jouer ce
rôle d'avant garde
mais jouer ce rôle d'avant garde dans le
contexte avec les principes que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure non pas pour
imposer
nous aspirons à jouer ce rôle d'avant
garde pour aider nos travailleurs nos
paysans nos intellectuels notre peuple
avancer dans la voie dont je parlais
donc voilà ce à quoi nous aspirons et
seront il suffit pas de le proclamer
comme on dit c'est sur le terrain qu'il
se gagne ce rôle d'avant garde
autrement dit fort est les meilleurs par
exemple les nombreux pays vont
s'efforcer pour nos repas la part qui
leur revient pas plus d'être les
meilleurs pour la grande dame lui-même
gamme
voilà un exemple à bordeaux on peut
alors cela étant dit j'ai bien compris
votre question me répéter apparaît peu
de temps
cela étant dit vous dites alors il se
peut que prochaines élections vous ne
soyez pas le premier parti c'est
possible chez les électeurs qui en
décideront alors je ne vous cache pas
que nous ferons tout pour que le parti
communiste français soit le plus
influent possible et nous le ferons
non pas par esprit de boutique et
chapelles mais nous ne verrons pas ce
que l'histoire enseigne à nos
travailleurs à notre peuple et je pense
qu'ils s'en souviendront que sans
l'existence d'un parti communiste fort
et influent il n'y a pas de progrès
social il n'y a pas de marche en avant
vers la démocratie
il n'y a pas de marche en avant vers le
socialisme
je peux même ajuster une chose et je
vais faire une référence il n'y aurait
pas d'union de la gauche et c'est
françois mitterrand lui-même qu'il l'a
dit s'il n'y avait pas un parti
communiste fort en france durera pas
besoin de la gauche par conséquent
affaiblir le parti communiste français
ce serait mettre en cause l'union de la
gauche et par là même toute perspective
démocratique
il peut être le parti d'avant garde si
par hypothèse il est le deuxième parti
électorale il peut quand même être le
parti d'avant garde il il peut aspirer à
jouer ce rôle et l'emmène à 6 de toute
façon ces électeurs qui veulent aider
ont bien sûr alors si nous sommes en 2d
oui ça n'enlèvera rien à votre à notre
volonté à notre à votre rôle
d'avant-garde à notre volonté profonde
d'être les meilleurs pour défendre des
intérêts de notre peuple pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain
je marchais je vous remercie d'avoir
passé cette heure avec nous prochain
invité de cartes sur table le mois
prochain
monsieur jacques chirac pour soir
[Musique]